Robin before we talk about writing beats
per minute I wanted to go back to the
90s when I understand that you had some
small affiliation with act up Paris yes
I'm wondering if you could take us back
to that time yes I was a working actor
Paris in 92 I entered the actor Paris in
92 and to be very clear about the the
whole story
it was 10 years after the beginning of
the epidemic in France who started in
the newspaper with newspapers because it
was related but we what was going on in
your country in the United States so we
heard that there was this kind of
epidemic there here so and I yeah it was
I was 29 in 82 so I was like a younger
guy and I discovered all this thing that
we are going on and I thought that was a
very bad science fiction thing that's
that was a kind of curse because in
France the newspapers were saying that
most of the gay people are we are going
to die gay man we are going to die of
these disease so it was really really
terrible but at the same time we were
shown at the like design another design
yes shown as a principle victim of this
epitomy with HIV drug users prostitutes
prisoners that there were no
communication to others you know so we
were to fixing but no one is we are
going to do anything that there was this
kind of indifference and I was so afraid
during ten years of what's going on and
lots of people that I knew we are going
to hospital it was a very weird
atmosphere of fear of yes it was like
especially for the gay man it was like
we were going back to the closet because
of this epidemic and because I lost a
friend of mine and I was not authorized
to visit him to the hospital
I was so angry which was well because it
was like our kind of couple of course we
were young so we were a kind of couple
but our couple didn't happen didn't
exist so I was very cross and I went to
accept in 92 because
his anger and that was in me you know so
I was I came to this group and it's like
in the feeling I was a newcomer and you
had this guy who was introducing you the
group and was explaining all the rules
which were very inspired by the act of
New York group of active San Francisco
groups and after you will in this
meeting and you didn't understand
anything and you didn't I didn't know
anyone and each was like swimming
jumping in a swimming pool and trying to
swim you know and I wanted the
spectators who believed this you know
this experience did you go with any of
the group to any of the expeditions or
you know protests you have to know that
I didn't do an historical film I did
this film out of my memories it's
exactly I didn't try to make an
historical thing I tried to reconnect
myself to the emotions sensations the
sensory reality and the sensuality that
we were going through at this time it's
not because all that is also political
and so I try to use all these memories
and I have a lot of very vivid memories
and because it's like when I was in the
group I was like a recording machine and
maybe unconsciously I was constructing
my film at the same time that I was
living this story maybe I don't know but
it took me like six months to write it
down because and I did it just with my
memories it's all wood you see in the
film happen and I was part of quite all
these actions and expeditions as you say
and all the debates also and I try to
put all this memory in the kind of
perspective and I try to find some kind
of contradiction contradiction
opposition between the characters which
were very important and meaningful to me
at the
time so you decided to write the script
at what point I mean these memories
lived in you for many many years and
then why now you know it's you don't
know why it's very weird it's I had this
conversation like yeah seven eight years
ago I think seven years ago because I
was preparing my previous film Eastern
boys and I was with my producers and one
of my producer was a friend of actor he
was a militant former militant and we
were joking and we were a lot of person
like ten person technicians and the
other producer which is a woman Maria
Christiani
and with my friend producer I was we
were kind of joking because I was
telling me I wanted to have more days of
shooting and he was telling me no but
it's too long and and I said to him you
owe me and he says to me no I don't owe
you anything I said you owe me big
because I dressed up your boyfriend when
he was dead and it's kinda it's hard to
stay but it's kind of joke between us
it's a running gag I think something
like this but the people around us were
a little bit shocked and it's we started
to talk about well what we were going
through at the time and that we thought
that was funny now but it was not that
funny at the time
and my other producers producer - Jenny
told me I know you want to do film about
that but you have to do it now because
if you if you wait too long you are not
going to do it anyway anymore and I
think that was true you know and so I
decided to do it and because I did my
previous film which was my second thing
a life I think I realized that I had
enough enough fluidity as a director you
know and that it was time enough to do
this film now I didn't think to be
honnest of the political world we are in
now United said but in Europe - you know
I did it in a selfish way because I had
to do it and
know this AIDS epidemic and cinema has
been the most important two things in my
life that was a that was a moment to
connect this two thing together and in
order to make this film you know I want
to talk about screenwriting but I just
want to jump to the rave scenes yeah
because they were very powerful because
you show these men and women enjoying a
very magical night but then there's
these globes of light can you explain
the metaphor behind that that's very
powerful it's very powerful but it's
also because you know it's um it's very
strange because people talk about but
the film like it's a very realistic and
it's very naturalistic in the way the
actions are playing which is true you
know that the actuals and especially the
French actors are playing like this you
don't see them so much playing you know
it's like very realistic and I love that
but the film has a very weird structure
because there's no outside of except in
the field for instance we are all if you
go out just for the actions but you
don't know about their family you don't
know about their personal life but I
mean there are the work you don't know
so much things you are really in a very
restricted area or restricted areas all
the time and well it for if it's like
for me like a science fiction film with
different time space like different
dimensions and one of the dimensions
other clubs and the clubs are for me of
a very important dimensions because it's
it's not related to the rest of your
life it's like going to the cinema way I
lived well well why I like cinema
theaters it's because it's a place you
go and you you are its collective but at
the same time you are alone on your own
so you are you have plenty pitcher or
alone and I like this idea you are in
the darkness and you are just looking at
light events which are magical sometimes
and and for me the clubbing very close
to cinema in fact and you are your
you go with friends and friends seems
very different because of lights and day
and at the same time you have to get
ever dancing and everyone is on his own
and there's this like in the film it's
like a collective thing at the same time
and something very intimate and
sometimes you realize that boy you know
or girl you know is very attractive
because you are in this kind of light
and this kind of atmosphere and I love
the fact that it's connect it's not
connected to the rest of the world and
so I tried also when I do films you know
I tried
I think films are about meat of
metamorphosis I like the fact that you
were in a film a character is becoming
some someone different that it's and you
can go come from a kind of raw to
another raw in a film from one
atmosphere to another atmosphere in the
same scene and I love this kind of
mutation metamorphosis because it's like
hallucinations that I love and in this
case for instance I wanted you know the
these fun moments this relief moments
that were the nightclub because of the
house music which we are very important
to us and because this music was fun but
at the same time the Wisconsin kind of
melancholy in it and therefore both a
lot of us it was like the soundtrack of
this epidemia at the time that was very
important you know and I wanted to show
that even in this kind of places you can
feel above the people like and through
the light you can see particles and when
you focus on these particles you can
think that it's kind of plasma and you
can see viruses or all cells of this
kind of thing it's because you know it's
more than a metaphor it's also because
we had in our back of our minds always
these represent a representations of the
virus because we were we are not only a
political group we were
how can I say an aesthetical group we
were of always thinking of the images of
this epidemic all the time and for
instance I remember that the president
of factor but the first president of
alpha of effective DG Lestrade was very
fascinated because kind of I don't know
what can a laboratory and pharmaceutical
group made photographs published
photographs of the first photography of
the virus attacking several human cell
and of course it was not natural picture
it was colors and everything you know it
was a little bit how can I say doctorate
and so in I was it was fascinating
because it was like looking at the enemy
confront the enemy clearly and so if he
did posters with these images so we were
working all the time on that so it's
like those people who are dancing
it's the images are like a treat to them
because we have and also because they
are imagining the virus and the other
world
the virus is working on our minds also
you know that was very important to us
at the moment so that and I try to make
very different club clubbing scenes
because at the end the last scene it's
like they are really on alone and it's
like a go spell for me it's like
everyone is for trying to survey from
for himself and that was important
because on this kind of scene at the
beginning there were kind of dialogues
in that scene and I decided it was just
only bodies dancing no dialogues and I
thought that was powerful because the
film is you have a lot of debates and
talking all the around in the
in the amphitheater since I wanted the
club to be just dancing and what one of
the reason we were trying to survive
it's not only because we want a job
because we want a life it was because we
were so good at aving pleasures and we
are so good because we were very young
and we were so good to go clubbing to
have sex to take drugs and all those
things we are so that was not fair well
then you played this song by Bronski
beat yeah which is such a beautiful song
and if you listen to the words
yeah it's anyone who's ever sort of left
a situation that's bad I invite anyone
to just look at the words of the song
and it's very powerful because that's
it's a beautiful song in itself but then
also to the the meaning behind it and
being alone that's kind of what that's
what it's about but you know this what
is strange it's mostly of course it's it
was released in 84 but it's a song
composed before the epitome it was it's
it's it's really about a young gay guy
who has to go back due to to live is a
small town to go to a capital city or to
a big town in order to leave his gay
life you know and it was the topic of
the other of the song but you know Jimmy
Summerville gave money to create actor
Paris because it was a very good friend
of De La Strada and he did also concert
for October and I was at this concert
and that was so emotional because when
he started to sing this song we were
like in 91 it was like not 10 years of
the epitome but quite and you know all
the people cried at this moment because
it was the song before epidemic and it
was the song of the start of the
epidemic and it was that like also like
as I say on the house music it was like
soundtrack of our personal lives and so
we were crying that was and so I asked
the Jimmy Hoffa movie but I wanted to
recreate this thing so I asked Jimmy
Somerville to be in the film doing the
we're doing the concert and everything
refused because he doesn't want to be
filmed which I totally understand I
would do that and he send us the
multitrack song recording of this song
you know and that was amazing really
because on the MIDI track you add the
track with his voice alone you know and
without reverberation and you can feel
so it's 84 or 83 and you can feel his
breath and you can feel the shock with
the microphone it's so incarnated like I
wanted my thing to be you know so I
asked my composer to make a remix like
in the 90s you know because my composer
are has all the instruments of this
period and is a DJ as well so he did new
remix of the song but during the editing
I decided because it's a moment in the
film where nothing feels so lonely
because he's going to a party and his
boyfriend is at the hospital and it
seemed that is disconnected from the
rest of the group because the collective
things cannot accompany them all the way
and so the is disconnected they had come
at some kind of distance and because
he's feeling so alone I wanted at the
end just to have the voice of Jimmy
Somerville like in his mind you know and
and the the that was so powerful to me
to stop all the rest of the instrument
that to stay with his voice without
reverberation a very dry sound you know
and at the end is breathing and I could
connect this breathing to the breathing
of shown at the hospital and so you know
the process I did I never regret I never
regretted the concert because I prefer I
thought it was more powerful like this
than to to recreate this concert which
was historical but it was not so many
for in this film and so that was a
chance anyway to work a little bit with
Jimmy Saville
you